I was doing blowing Colorado all right
but it was a fruitless thing that no one
cared no one it's hard to sell coke
there I don't know whether it's not as
the elevation just the way the way of
life there they're more interested in
like you know much mushrooms and acid
and stuff and I don't know I quit
wearing a watch when I moved out here
wow that's so cool ya know like my cell
phone has a clock on it so I don't
really need it a large black coffee what
large black coffee do you mean a venti
no I mean a work he means a venti yeah
the biggest fun you that venti is large
no venti is 20 yeah large is large in
fact tall is large and Grande is Spanish
for large meant he's the only one that
doesn't mean bar it's also the only one
that's Italian congratulations you're
stupid in three languages you want to
get a massage or do something fun it's a
bit 40s huge I'm turning 38 okay
38 you will move on isn't it weird that
our birthday is the same week and then
we're gonna have a party and it's just
for me no I don't think it's weird at
all no weird though when you have a kid
and all your dreams and hopes just go
right out the window what changed for
you what went out the window
what plans you do everything exactly the
same no I mean I love with them do it no
like say okay say you know before you're
married and have children you want to go
live in India for a year you can do it
but you can't do it once you have a
family you want to go live in India I
don't want to go live in India do you
want to go to India go to India
seriously go to India what about you do
you want to go to India I'm not going to
end yet you know you're gorgeous
all right and popular and and but this
is not why I you know I come here this
is a good learning experience for me oh
he said that
what are you doing here David let's go
to Paris I want to take you underneath
the Eiffel Tower and make love to you
cut what out this go to Paris we've
broken up for like two years man I don't
want to date you anymore you're a [ __ ]
I am NOT a [ __ ] I just didn't like you
this is so us psycho talk what am I
suppose to methey Dalton Oh tea dull oh
hey that's pretty good
tell you what give me your best Bond
impression why don't you get off your
board and get on get out to view my
dreams and into my car are you are
you're looking for your pot of gold why
does everything I do sound like a
leprechaun you tell me it's made with
bits of real panther so you know it's
good it's quite pungent oh yeah it's a
formidable scent stings the nostrils in
a good way yeah Brian I'm gonna be
honest with you that smells like pure
gasoline they've done studies you know
60% of the time it works every time
that doesn't make sense well let's go
see if we can make this little kitty
purr